my ice cream like chocolate I like pizza
and cheese like a dude is hurt ain't
dance night dance Steven I just got
dance oh my god
[Music]
episode induce here we are busily
welcome to the respire team podcast Eric
G induce energy and deduce that I have
the year anniversary of that poster so
on you want to bring something up this
episode yeah I want to I'm not gonna
call you I noticed that towards the end
you would want to play with us but what
he got on you no no no we're not
bringing up the right thing let's really
talk about the real issue is the Craig
Frank beef I think it was just late at
night and we were like not doing well on
something that I just got upset and then
I would just you know literally look
like you know the same person you're
like the white version of the group I
didn't know like what you guys looked
like so like when I got Craig in the
prank mixed up all the time
is this I don't know why we had beef but
I mean yeah but look it below you guys I
know what the problem is you know I'm
stepping in here the problem is general
Craig over here likes to tell everybody
what to [ __ ] do I don't you just you
just call the shots and we'll follow you
yeah I'm saying all I know is I say we
go left cuz we're getting tagged all
right so general Craig says go left is
that the first order sir I'm just saying
that's my general category left
the advantage is you alright general
crag is that fan that's not me all right
crank you there Griffin [ __ ] I got
tagged on the bridge watch out
the guys coming to my or watch eyes
coming they're coming in oh yeah yeah
got that my biggest pet peeve well
simply playing trial waiting trials with
crane you're not doing well so Craig
like we need to do this man we go
together and then I'm like okay we'll
come with me and then he'll be like no I
don't like that spot and I'm like so are
we just supposed to like don't work her
and Craig you like to go to the worst
like I'll never forget we kind of dad we
got into it a little bit it was on black
shield because they have the outside the
cap points out so this is ice
everybody's using ice breaker so like if
you don't go get that outside point
they'll just scope that hallway from the
other end and wait for the point and
take the point to win that's true so a
lot of good snipers right we we couldn't
really go inside he's like well I'm
doing better inside I'm like dude
they're just gonna go to the point wait
and that's what they do well okay so so
in my defense of that situation and how
this includes Steve because a lot of
time it be me Steven come clarify just
to clarify coke is good
very good good I mean nobody's here's
gonna like coke will take any of us
he'll kill any of us for sure you know
unless he's like because I have
something to say to you do I did you
okay all right I'm gonna say about this
to Craig and you follow me
let's my feelings is you say oh you do
steve is you get my pick up pills
okay we'll get to that I mean there's no
offense everything hurts your feelings
let me get back to so coke so my thing
and by the way I think we've actually
gotten better when we did when the bus
three yeah like Griffin said when you
have two guys that aren't that great
affinity it doesn't matter how good that
one person is you're not once you get to
that eight not at ninth game you're not
gonna win right when you're going
against right three really good yeah
sweaty fun right this is an unfair
example because when cokes playing yeah
he's doing the majority of the work
that's trick the problem happens when
the three of us are playing and you're
mister like let's go
we died I'm gonna next time guys we
gotta go left that's to die I think we
got it
it's like and you never want to do what
anybody else wants to do no no I am
doing like a hundred yard dash yeah he's
just he's running he's just he's not
shooting
and I'll see Craig on the map just over
you know different conversation because
when he's saying I played with those
three and me and you will be together
and Steve will be somewhere else so I
don't think that's a fair example of
that one cuz we've had that on both what
we're thinking of being together is
completely different because you think
from like being able to see me from like
you know 200 feet away is close
that's not close because by the time
they kill you what what they do in
trials is once they put one hurt paper
trial day they take one person does it
right babe and they they control the
board so we can't get the rebound so if
we're a you're if you're far away yeah
you may be close in terms in Craig's
terms close you're not really close
because I'm only so good that's the
whole reason we got logically up titles
but only one against three people that
are like my level or just just good
I still can't three guns against one Joe
Joe yeah again but again though the main
problem is this guy's not a team player
it's like you see here you hear their
suggestions right
[Laughter]
so when I play with now my defense for
Griffin and Steve here we go is that
when I play with you guys if I don't
move and say something we don't move
that is no my god guys we gotta go right
then it's like nobody else can make a
suggestion
hey is this what you do you suggest mr.
passive-aggressive yeah mr.
passive-aggressive so let's say the last
round Steve we went left cuz Steve did
something and I will say let's do this
Craig and it's like well I would have
done that you know I was busy you know
Steve was down and I couldn't get her
help that's what you do right I'm not
gonna defend the fact that I sometimes I
was the one time we work the best as a
team well you played with notes the
dungeons remember we got seven wins
you're right and we we owe the Draenei
the drive the game we lost that gave us
the loss on a record was competitive we
didn't get look like it was a close game
with I went for more what's the last
yeah you pulled some when I had to go I
had to go off-book to get hurt by the
Green was already killed all three
literally just standing by the green
hammer
we'll get there let's go back as you
wanna beat up on so you come back to
your point and you have to admit this
I'll take my responsibility but you have
to admit you have to admit that
sometimes you would wait for me to go
first and get capped and then you would
cap somebody well it's called team
shooting team shot but you would wait
for me to go over you wouldn't go in
front of me I I apologise him no no I'm
not apologize that like you would do
that sometimes things frustrating good
cuz I practice in my practice PV
bathroom I'll get really angry and I
still can't let's talk about trials
trial for people that don't know trial
is like the hardest thing it's the
competitive three people versus a mink
it is the most infuriating it's so hard
unfun like cuz it's like no matter what
we do is the thing i you kid frustrates
me about it the games really fun when
you're in a competitive match yeah look
if you're in a competitive match and you
feel like you have a chance
yeah you're like oh my god even if you
lose you're like that was fun it's worth
the loss but most of the time is like
good when Steve and I are playing we get
stomped we're getting stomped in Lincoln
IV we just start your gun or you get
into a shooting match with someone and
you think like well I'm doing what
they're doing and then it's like not
dead but you're not they're doing
something different you know they're not
so with the one point you know what are
we doing wrong what ending Steve yeah
thank you the reason you die so fast is
because they're team shooting they're
aware of where the people are coming and
they're there's not one gun because when
it's everybody just one on one that's
where you're gonna have matches where
you guys you find oh I get a speaking to
me to kill or something like that it's
really funny team is so close I should
get you to I saw that I don't know but I
saw that dude
I play another Grenadier Drake well
that's exactly what's happening felt
like you guys didn't see the footage
from the first Kings the first games
like I was like they just would go
there's none of this waiting it was like
they knew the spot they wanted to find
that and they were just jumping around
and moving but I just move yeah yeah
like you know and like that when you get
good you can so it's map map awareness
oh yeah but we know the maps at this
point yeah we do it's just so it tries
just so people understand trials of 3v3
and it's usually the best people in the
game it's the elite it's the only
encoding which is what nine matches five
nine nine matches five rounds per match
right and then get together so there's a
place called the lighthouse it's 45 the
lighthouse is where you get the cool
[ __ ] it's like Oh everybody wants to go
there but you can't have a Plymouth and
you can't write uqba wrong get one you
get eight wins you got yet to get nine
right is behind if you win the first one
with a bone you get you right you have
them you get him forgiven right if you
don't get her forgiven its nine wins in
a row
right so thank you so so you have to
play you have to beat nine teams of
three people who are usually definitely
better than me in sometimes they cheat
and sometimes stuff happens
the thing is drinking game you guys hit
trials though when it got really hard
the reason because because when you guys
started playing trials they change the
matchmaking so like it's randomized
those those those first seven games
right are random like you can any team
you can run into good good teams but
you'll get like lower-level people
those last two matches they do
matchmaking where your matchmaking with
another team that's doing really well
yeah like they're they're also they're
also trying to get some that's why you
noticed those last two games I'm like I
always think it's harder after five how
do I get harder yeah yeah we can have
you done this some teams do plays I feel
like they have formations like I'll be
this one guy will bait me and jump up
and I'll should be shooting him but
there's a guy
kind of sniping me there's method to
that madness
they planned that out but there's also
like really good people like when we
played there was one time as me and Bob
remember we played this one jerk with
the no man's land or whatever the hell
it's called the sniper right oh no man
beyond
no land beyond worst and and the guy in
the device was toy he didn't his team
wasn't even playing it was just him and
he was rolling in I was with you me and
Bob and yo-yos and it was so in
generation so we were getting like he
was sniping all of us and you just she's
gonna be love right now so - oh yeah he
would channel step boom yeah we die and
that was it was just Austria and we
couldn't even be one guy no we couldn't
have been he was [ __ ] with he was
skin so bored yeah but that kind of
stuff is in theory I know the next time
sometimes I've had times wrong playing
destiny where I just go I think
everybody said it well it's one even I
said you know when they started
announcing destiny - I'm like I'm gonna
take a break you're just watching to
bring - good cause I went to go I took
this clown to the play in that first
mission from the beta yeah yeah we
played that mission there but I don't
when you got that event you're in this
big warehouse and all the Bungie stuff
is there and you're playing it was like
it was like it was so smooth and I was
like oh why still play destiny it was
like even here's another thing that's
frustrating is even though we've been
playing it out for three years and like
everybody's got my level 400 a week but
but like there are things that you don't
have there's no point in getting them
anymore
like what example like like whatever gun
or exotic armor you don't have or
whatever like mission where you have to
do likes you know thank you swords and
stuff like that
what's the point of it now cuz yet but I
feel like they're the prizes from things
are not enough anymore
yeah like you know like you had you a
mmmm when you used to do a nightfall and
guess and at the end of the night now
looks like you know you don't get it's
not even worth it that's why you've been
even light on the trial subject that's
why even trials is worse because the
only people playing this game are super
like PvP diehards yeah you know what I'm
saying Brandon I don't like that it
should be balanced like normal people
just like us like I was saying another
one they didn't have the match mate they
didn't match mate based on your record
it was random so it's actually really
easy to get to the lighthouse Oh once
you could go against a bunch if you got
a lucky draw how many times we get a new
card you'd get a lucky draw where you
get a bunch of bad teams you know you've
got where everybody's lucky draw oh yeah
yeah well hey we made sure they listen
but now everybody's so sweaty
I mean destiny to it it'll it'll go
through that process again it'll be
easier and destiny to because there's
gonna be so many so when I when I did
the multiplayer that was I was like oh
this is gonna be fun well and that I
mean touchin on d2i it's more gunplay
yeah they're making it more you have to
be good with your primary you can't spam
well your supers are nerfed like you
don't get your super as much to save
their raids you get yeah and the stinky
zoning you played you baby there baby no
day you think I drop you yeah I drop the
murdering the see that's like my
imbalance but I don't understand it's
like I think if you have a grenade that
kills all the renames should kill like I
don't mind a grenade killing people it's
a freaking grenade yeah okay and then
they had like the shoulder charge was an
instant kill I think if you have full
melee power you should kill like the
there's any although should be a kill
and that's not I never understand yeah
have to hit him twice I think yeah my
right I think you're gonna do one why
not oh I think the reason they're not
doing it because I mean sucks like if
we're taking shoulder charging well the
spike grenades not many with that you
have two right now in the back off area
and that's me you see a lot more times
than anything else yeah I know it's not
because they can make all worden to call
the Titan ski because all right hundred
right there every class has their own
thing they're good at right Hunter's are
supposed to be fast right
warlocks have really good recovery so I
can get hurt you recover fast Titans
have really good armor but the thing is
Titans have really good armor and with
things like Twilight garrison and
shoulder charge for movement they're
actually faster than hunters right so
they're fabulous members and they got
more armor so like you're seeing a lot
of Titans cuz they got one-hit kills
things like closer so it would the same
thing it with weapons people are going
to exploit one they're only gonna play
that one way so that's it that's why I
agree with you know taking the abilities
down so people aren't just spamming
abilities same thing with sticking your
names in trials now you a lot of people
that run warlocks how Craig we went to
the lighthouse yeah we and I know the
guy he's really not that good well I
want to talk about that so so the people
that went to lighthouse you've got a
thousand times
yeah we're just gonna discount that cuz
their husbands you never win never Oh
Steven every so griffin recently yeah
when I was and you will with Grenadier
Jake and you uneventful on it that it
was uneventful because it's like did
just he didn't we did it with this other
guy he was playing with and I'm not the
guy that he was playing with was better
than him yeah oh and we went like like
it just POW yeah it was there I'll be
able to see it on my phone you know what
I mean
that's how I do it yeah sure oh really
oh [ __ ] okay I can't where's my twitch
app
I gotta find twitch oh [ __ ] I can't do
all three in this little closet guys
okay I'm I'm gonna stay outside
I tagged to the landing in well I got my
Chile stole mo I'm gonna look around the
lighthouse and we're walking around the
White House my mom just came in mom I
just went flawless on destiny so funny
wait wait the first game we played I
killed two people and I was like yeah I
must have got like four kills the whole
the whole or the whole in nine cards
because and that for lack of trying
it's just they're so good maybe we just
let's go it was like [ __ ] I get my green
ham we went yeah it was it was
depressing and I'll tell you why because
we've tried so many times like us to
tell me no no no no I'm just saying the
general son a bit but no no but the guy
we played with was so painful to play
with he was he was so people knew who he
was this dude he's ordering you around
but but also like you know that for you
they like you know they got I'm disabled
in the game right you know we're not
good like you know what I mean so then
like the guy is like on me constantly
like he's like why didn't you go over
there and take a hit again yeah he's
getting mad at me and I'm like I'm not
good that's what you knew that you yes
before you knew we're not good that's
why you even looked at my art kill death
yeah he's like I looked at you I see so
much I you know like easily get on my
shoulder charge yeah KD whatever well
you know that's one thing about Pete but
those type of games so I play another
game division yeah and this is I did a
vision I like destiny but what I don't
like it like when you're playing the
game right and then like you play with
somebody you don't know and then their
mic is on and we're just like like we're
having fun yeah the only reason we like
one of the main things about I was
saying let's say 40% of what makes
destiny so great is the fact that you're
because even when the game is such a
[ __ ] nonsense I'm talking to you guys
alright but I can't stand you're playing
with somebody and somebody's like come
on
with these two British kids who are
hilarious
we're having a good time and this guy's
coming inside sure yeah sure like I
didn't even have to Steve and I had
unspoken communication yeah yeah we just
know just some playing I was like okay
cuz the Xu's team went quiet I was like
huh and they were playing crota and then
like we didn't know you don't play cool
it is you trying to kill crow to go to
the right side yeah that's what we do
sounds like guys go to the left because
I told them I'm like no like I've done
this a million times right
and my biggest pet peeve is when you get
those guys there's there's someone
that's kind of in between you got the
really good sweaty players that yeah
they're really good they can be a dick
but I hate the people that think they're
better than they are
and maybe if they die you can't be
horrible and you're getting else
well I die because that was jealous they
go we plan and leave a function you
shouldn't have popped your super that's
a yeah I went off oh yeah we were texted
but I just I I just I was screaming at
him and then he like like like yeah
yeah but also though dude
I was like wait why do we here in that
guy's New Zealand guy you said something
that kind of hurt me to him to the New
Zealand guy no said I went over to his
place
yeah and you showed me the footage oh oh
he does is a warlock he does sticky
grenades in the uses a [ __ ] right in
my face
no I was saying I was saying like so so
like cuz that's your weapons you like
stickies into Leyla no the way you said
it is that's on skill players do that I
didn't say unskilled dude he's like
using stickies and a Toledo he goes
you're good with the grenades but you
don't rely on sticky goodness yeah this
guy yeah this guy he would use rocket
and trials I think the last match of he
had like he was 19 and four Oh like yeah
you were doing better than me and trial
Oh us yeah he was Kim that's why he was
talking a big game but what he was doing
was running two stickies and he had
another armor armor or perk on that
it'll kill revived players oh yeah it's
just a fire that's fine that is even
even if someone has the over shield or a
lot what he would do is he would wait
around a corner and he his gun skill
wasn't that good he'd wait around a
corner wait for a guy to provide them
and throw it at the reverb guy and take
them down this guy got 19 kills I'm
gonna say 13 14 of them we're all sticky
grenades that's why I say what the one
hit like they exploit the [ __ ] out of
that that's all you see in trials all
you see in trials are ice breakers
Wormwood's
palindrome and stickies palin palindrome
something in him of them whatever hand
cannon they dare expert with I wasn't
even thinking I even didn't remember you
play what so laylock at that point I was
just talking about you oh yeah you don't
know
and play live there's no power Tilly's
do because honestly his Duggan didn't
know he was talking to me and we played
privates remember that right after cuz
he's like I'll take I'll take you guys
both on you know it like that and we got
we got arrow in there we started
stomping I know well don't forget I was
I was playing it and I just stopped cuz
I didn't wanna I didn't want to go yeah
I didn't need with us that's right but
if you got off and me me and arrow were
on what was he using and was he running
well I said he said he wouldn't he's
like you think all I use the stickies
I'll use something else when he use
something else he got completely trashed
yeah not even joking
Mike so it's not even his get his map
awareness was good in trials he's a very
sweet to her trials player but that's
what he relies on that so like going
back to the destiny to that's what I
think is it's good about taking that
down because sticky grenades have crazy
aim-assist oh yes I get stuck by sticky
that's like it should be past me but
it'll like but I can't stand you don't
see it you know you know are you hear
that no but that's why I liked it -
listo because like you know nobody know
it's not the a pissed after oh that
explain you kill me I'm gonna kill you
let's talk about let's talk about the
king of the green animal you need to get
green if you love you love in which but
you are like the king no one they took
away where you can't get the you know
you don't keep your green animal right
when they took that away it became like
you had to go get the green apple yeah
you ments like his priority number one
yeah he's always at the green do a top
five fusion rifles with Eric right now
we have a top five on the spine hmm yeah
I think someone from the war machine
raid oh yeah machine Nova yeah yeah it's
super clear something no yeah yeah no
ether no
everyone I think even over is great yeah
I think that's actually actually the
best fuse where I found really things
playing see ya okay to Plan C I think
Clancy's number one charge the charge
but no if you're really gonna say if
you're really gonna go just based solely
on fusion rifle then the best fusion
rifle is no no no the best fusion rifle
is the heavy one
what's it called defects here on the few
one that's been the class was the best
your one was the best can and then Plan
C okay what's three and then I would
think that I think that more machine
okay number three because no matter what
class you when you doing burns okay
alright what to make to make quick shot
because like I'm not big on fusion
rifles the guy we play with arrow
he's [ __ ] good with this brand see
because it's so quick yeah because
that's just like of a ether Nova like
there's a lot of them that are on the
same level that's better you know this
you're saying it just depends on what
role you get they're all the same
I like the salty the reason why people
you sell individual you it's better
because they it clumps all of them
nothing that they're they're more
together because a lot of them happen
the charge rate isn't high actually see
it to be really good with it I'm gonna
go I'm a dick if you miss what if you
want to know
okay because I don't use user idols but
I will say you're one for like secondary
fusion rifle year one the most
ridiculous gun was on Pocket infinity oh
yeah because because it's like an auto
one so like when you shoot it I'll shoot
you right X yeah shoot six verse it's
still in the game it's made nerfed it
though because I played a guy but you're
one when you started with yeah so like
you would have two or three this place
to start pvp you could walk into a room
and just spray it and it was so strong
it would just I played a guy that was so
good with it I like you it wasn't even
competitive I couldn't even get my gun
off cuz he just spray it and they they
ended up nerfing it but that in its
heyday was unreal that's a tough parties
cuz like if you get good people that are
good with the gun that's already a gun
that's unbalanced it's it's like it's
impossible
clean breakers bows like now clean with
Cooper yeah but you mentally you have to
be enduring
that's like a that was a good sniper
rifle I was and it really bugs actually
delete it and stuff like that I was
talking to arrow and competitive play
like real competitive play like actual
tournaments and they ban the Queen
greatest oh really
and I was like why did they do that and
I used to use it here and there I
actually used it recently in private
matches and I was [ __ ] destroying
with that yeah even since the Amos
sister said Oh hon you don't have to hit
in the head and a lot of times the
registers of the headshot and also with
what you said about the green ammo the
special ammo if there's not as much so
like what's crazy about the clean
breakers bow is when you pick it up you
get what you could get up like 12 shots
yeah you know what I'm saying you don't
get independent what armor you have on
Queen breakers bow and the range on that
was yeah goodness yeah freaking because
you can switch it to where it was a
medium range to combat sights yes so
what's your like worst good let's go
let's go talk let's go rounds the top
five primaries let's go this way this is
like what's your best good
what do you like what do you like my
favorite got obviously got some Alec
there was my favorite one I love pulse
rifles so much so grass from Alec clever
dragon was great I just started [ __ ]
what happened I just started [ __ ]
with hand cannons I was laying the game
to have some humour would have been
running lately but it has luck in the
draw
so those two I thousand-yard stairs well
my favorite oh you still got that yes Oh
whatever you PvP game that's what
everybody yeah that's actually why we
will you like Frank early on cuz he was
you said that that's why we like Frank
no no but none of us sniped we needed
Frankie did you very D is my favorite
shotgun that that was a nerve that I
feel like the matador took over the
matter nice take over but I had this one
role and I never liked shotgun yeah I
had a conspiracy theory what was when
you aim it extends the range rangefinder
rangefinder is also like it's just extra
damage yeah yeah it's so good I'm trying
to look at my own yeah because they're
preparing for they've got a new destiny
to F yeah sucks
oh my gun my my favourite obviously my
is Charlie okay so who I liked imago Lou
one of the rolls you like oh my god roll
it's a god roll God role would be
rangefinder rangefinder rifle barrel
rifle barrel look in the paper
well yeah alright so see you like a Mago
yeah with a Mago Luke Florida hi fixer
right there all hand cannons yeah just
doing
he's good Lord - our scenes here Kenan's
one that I year one hanging near one
it's called the Venetian and that was
one Smith it was a dead orbit hand
cannon oh and what I'm a dead orbit guy
yeah yeah yeah it pissed me off cuz
you're the or generated so people know
it's like a faction it's a faction
there's there's three different factions
you know you can join by the way you're
one guns you're one year - those are the
best yeah yeah when they had those when
they had legendaries with burns on yeah
like all the crota guns yeah those were
the days yeah you know I'm still missing
with them you know they brought him back
but yeah and now with burns they're
exotic so yeah um but uh is the nation
and it was a dead orbit one but it was
weird the way they did it because what
the vendors they have the guns that you
can you can buy them you can buy them
from the vendors this hand cannon you
couldn't buy you had to get it through a
package I thought was right
so it was even rarer there's more rare
and hard to get but I had that [ __ ]
with feeding frenzy what you killed with
it make the reload faster
I had send it and before they nerfed
send it send it was like rifle barrel
but it didn't even slow down your reload
so I added increased target acquisition
and it had range so it's kind of like my
imago now but Benner does the reload is
better so I had it was send it and then
I had outlaw which precision kills make
the reload thing so and no stacked those
abilities so and literally it was the
fastest reloading game like again I have
game gameplay of it and it doesn't even
make sense how fast this gun reloads
like if I get a head shot kill he's like
boom like it's like we don't reactive
reload on it no because they didn't have
that problem yes
okay but that was those would be your
mains those were my main three yeah well
you won't have two more just for fun all
right
I don't want to kill her rivals I love
the ice breaker I don't like it now cuz
everybody uses it but I use it near one
not very many people use it legendary
exciting I'm like I like the one I got
now it's a dead orbit one with hidden
hands
I'll bet horizon no someone's gonna be
listening this and just screaming yeah
yeah I forget it's called but it's like
a it's a high fiery it doesn't do a lot
of damage but it's like it's quitting
things so like you can get two quick
bodies if you don't get the headshot but
those those are probably my my top my
top five but the imago loop and you stay
with your primary oh yeah well and I'm
and what they did with the game recently
that nerfing of the game they it's like
primary it made everybody use I mean I'm
a huge nerd I'm very OCD about how my
guy looks oh yeah like my fader matches
my gun well that's and I'm super pumped
for destiny too because they're adding
weapon shaders so you know I'd change
any gun you have you can change it to
make it look like it coordinates with
yeah let's go to use go
what are you okay well I'm gonna start
off with the PDA is 45 45 Hawk saw there
was um dead orbit had a great scout
rifle that got rid of it's called the
hung jury yeah I remember that one thank
you rocking it somehow this man I am you
can't great so I know that I changed the
bedroom and obviously the might of
multi-tool
[Music]
if I was Top Gun I would say just give
me the minor multi do as I would just
use that the moment I know you're gonna
say the hopscotch pilgrim I was gonna
say oh that was okay but I like the
minor - oh yeah then till a lock then
till they lock and then for fusion
rifles of the Saladin's vigil and yeah
that's about the ow yeah yeah you like
I'm with you I like thought the might I
mean cuz the minors out on your lips
yeah that's that stuff that's up there
definitely hopscotch
I did I did love the Monte Carlo I got
burned oh let's face that Craig doesn't
like any guns silver charger
shoulders right oh but I like that and
then shotguns were oh I love shotguns
we're about top five shotguns I'm gonna
top 5s too many three three like a
matador I bet you it has something to it
it has nothing to do with the actual
shotgun so much that it has to do with
the amount of damage it did and then
like the little perks you have on it all
the shotguns were the same kind of this
a it just depends on like which one you
got like if the matador 64 had that huge
spare rain oh no who's like if you had
range that's the thing shamans are all
about range if you want to get somebody
first ability your blood in the heyday I
don't know if you guys remember this but
was failed once there's life max range
and before they took though they took
because I am daughter the game's entire
band took the perk out of the game
because everybody goes range fighter now
when it was spread shot
spread shot made it so it wasn't right
it stayed in like a small cone so you
could you could kill people from like a
mile away with it well the one it was on
one I don't like which is surprisingly
to many people like is the universal
remote and my conspiracy theory I
that's just some scrubs yeah well my and
you if you are so so totally based on
the side that you need uses primarily
right no that's what I'm saying I'm on
your team though I would literally
jumping in I didn't go invisible and I
just shoot everything I feel like a guy
I'll tell you the one I like though more
than Matador is the party crasher party
I like the party crasher and then yeah I
mean that would be it I mean and other
than that all the rest kind of seen the
same like the invective and all that
seemed like they were like I like that
you know I don't know but they also
nerfed them so much now that it was my
favorite shot anchor is the one where
you kill someone in a brings ammo back
to here that was bone Mulligan no
performance bonus that was that was I
had that on the conspiracy theory and
that was like that was rangefinders
perfect yeah it was amazing
what about I think my all-time favorite
gun in the game of all time though is a
vision of comfortable Oh the scout rifle
I remember going back to going back when
like when we met that's that that was
the tweet he tweeted Bungie he was like
you know I love this game for you guys
making there's an a confluence because
when they because they you know what you
know they yeah they fooled us they told
us what I did not ever appreciate about
destiny's when he went to that like Lord
of wolves and wolves thing yeah yeah it
was supposed to be 150 new guns and all
this done and it was like it wasn't it
wasn't you wait here they all sucked and
you carry on I was like no they got rid
of all you guys because then they had
the guns but there was only one 6160 yes
Frank I thought that was the biggest
mistake they made wewe should they
should have kept
I should have kept them all the gun for
diversity yeah but like am I gonna use a
lot is I have my app open is the steel
medulla yeah and the reason why I like
it is because I have full stability
all right that's like what stability
protein have on there yeah but it's just
a full stability that's what I need to
have and I have a hopscotch children
with the same thing but they have and
this one can be fired fully auto and
missing a shot from far up alright so
let's listen I want to bring up another
thing no idea why I don't know so I want
email 1747 alright but before you get
there next time so let's talk about
Frank hi Frank what I was remembering my
[ __ ] bong noises separate pit away
ice cream I like chocolate I like pizza
and cheese I like hot
did you get anything for your munchies
no I need you though I might I mean
we're just playing some I mean I might
go run down to the store so I get like
where do you go at night
I don't know I mean I I can't the
problem is like if I go I don't like I
shouldn't be like eating you know it's
too late
one minute left
zone eight capture you have zone advance
I'll be 45 minutes guys
so whenever to be texting me the whole
time some of the times will be funny is
like even in our early days when Frank
would like get high and then we don't
pass out and then we're shooing Horry
standing there and then the other day
was funny because you got high and then
you you ordered Thai food and then he
disappeared for like a half an hour and
at the end were like Frank are you Frank
cream plane and then he gets on goes I
gotta be pad thai guys and then you just
hain't you just get off it was the
funniest [ __ ] to me you were on for like
half an hour they have funny little you
know well I like to play when I'm
relaxed
you put together yes
don't make me laugh friends sleeping on
the couch and I'd have to play in
everyone
yeah you to all of you guys well gets
another episode I think
[Music]
[Applause]